foreign
the greatest food in America and talk to
Zach what's up Zach
hello Dr John how we doing
I'm living the dream
anybody who says I'm living the dream is
never living the dream what's up dude I
I got to apologize I'm not an original
text and I just moved here so oh no
where'd you move from
uh Hawaii uh we'll take you for sure
okay yeah dude are you are you
originally from Hawaii
no uh I was in the Navy so I moved
around a lot so actually I grew grew up
mostly on the west coast different
states
uh so you came to be converted huh yep
well congratulations man never too late
never too late welcome to the to the
Lone Star State and I just rhymed so I'm
a rapper too what's up man
uh well no I know I sent you an email
and um it sounded really Doom and Gloom
um I didn't get it I don't uh then they
don't give those to me Jenna just gets
them so we have to have a we can have a
natural conversation so tell me about it
okay
well you know I had originally asked you
know how do I just find the will to move
on you know just just so many layers to
this onion that I try to narrow down my
question to you know for your show and a
lot of it you know just kind of revolves
around my second ex-wise
um okay
so the back story on that is
um I was originally married back in 2017
and the marriage last about maybe a year
and a half and it was a very rough
marriage
I was able to escape that marriage and
after I dug out of prison I went back to
the front door and louder back into my
life and I'm just starting to regret
that so are you all still together
uh yes it's uh I don't know how much
time you have I can tell you the full
story go for it man
um so when I got married in 2017 it was
after a year of dating um
shortly by me like four months after we
got married she had accused me of abuse
yeah so
no sir you're good man take a breath
take a breath dude you're all good
so you know after four months you know
just really affected me was it totally
was it all fabricated
it was um it was just I think because
to give a little you know
you know a little context there you know
she's just
um an irrational person or just really
insecure some bipolar and they're just
you know a little dash of Tourette's
right
and um so
she you know she was hitting me and
everything so I held down her arms to
stop her from hitting me like then I
think I guess one of her therapists saw
the you know the markings on her arm so
they reported that
and um and that led off to a whole you
know a year-long investigation and then
mandatory counseling
and so on and uh were you charged
criminally
no I wasn't I mean and well because in
the military you know you're guilty
until proven guilty right so it doesn't
matter if you're
if you're found you know not guilty
because it's never about that just about
you know making sure that spouse is safe
and the member is safe did you get
court-martialed
uh no I did go uh get um what we call
non-judicial punishment and uh it wasn't
related to
the actual abuse it was related for me
violating uh a order given by my
commanding officer
um and that was just in order for not to
talk to the spouse
um and then
uh so for you know for the entire year
and a half that we were married I was
actually not living at home for a good
year and I had to have my own place I
was paying for two places at the time in
Hawaii of all places yeah it's expensive
um so bring me up to right now you you
got cleared of everything you you did
your non-traditional punishment you
learned whatever lessons you need to
learn
so you know in order well so after the
year and a half that we were married
I divorced her and
she refused to leave so she became a
squatter in my house and so for three
years after that
I lived with her living there she just
refused to believe that we were divorced
refused to believe that there was no
relationship why didn't you call the
police Act
ideas and the police says there's
nothing they can do
um this was even after an episode where
she got insanely crazy how do I hate to
use a term but then I had locked myself
in the spare room and she kicked the
door in broke it literally in half and I
called the cops and cops said well
there's nothing they can do because she
lives there and I was like well because
this was the other way around I think
cops are ready of course but yeah so I I
it must just be difference in how
Hawaii's laws work but if you're
divorced if you've got divorce papers
juggle through the proceedings
everything was finalized
yeah I mean so Hawaii has a rule where
you know you serve the papers and they
don't respond within 20 days you could
be a divorce by default correct and so I
mean I did that
um
so I had I you know did this whole
year-long plan I was gonna convince her
that we're all moving to Texas together
as then I had to sell my house I put on
the plane and send it to her parents
and I moved to Texas you know because I
told you I had to stay behind to finish
some work stuff
and when I got to Texas I
um
you know I didn't have anybody here it
was just me and um I'll certainly you
know lonely and everything so start
talking with her again then
um we had agreed that you know we're
going to try this out again and if she
comes back we're going to try it out if
it doesn't work out she's gonna go back
home okay bring me to bring me to right
now man bring me to right now
um it just right now
um is she back living with you again she
is back living with me and I told her
she had to leave but she just yeah that
you can't possibly think that she's
gonna leave
yeah she's not you know of course not
she never has there's nothing I can do
to get her to leave did I even called
her parents parents can't do anything
you know uh
you can call the police and you can in
Texas and I know this
you can call the sheriff's department in
Texas and say I have broken up with my
girlfriend
and she refuses to leave my property of
which she has zero claim
okay we are divorced she needs to go
and she is refusing to leave I need
assistance
okay okay had that exact conversation
and now listen none of this matters if
three months from now you call her back
get invite her back over
yeah I'm just yeah it was it was really
stupid okay I just you know I mean I
just like really living the same traumas
for the past five years I was just
living in flight mode and goes I I got
you I got you but bro you I mean
did you learn your lesson now I mean you
got you you got bit
by a rattlesnake for three years and
then you get to Texas and you're like
I'm gonna put my hand back in that bag
and get bit again that's exactly what I
did and just
yeah and she's clearly struggling she's
got a lot going on that you can't solve
but man you can protect yourself and
keep you safe right
yeah and it's it's just yeah I
understand it just I I'm afraid to do
anything because if I say anything it's
gonna just
open up a whole can of worms where
here's the thing Zach I would I would
record I would record our conversations
I would call the sheriff's department
today
and I would make as clean and as quick a
break as possible while also treating
her with dignity and respect you brought
a person who's not well back into your
life into a situation where they have
faltered before
okay and so she's not well
she's not stable and she makes things
very hard she makes up stories she put
you through year of proceeding she
wouldn't leave your house she wouldn't
she doesn't acknowledge reality fine I'm
gonna give her the benefit of the doubt
and just assume that she is very very
sick
but you
put her back in a situation where she
has never been successful in the past
and so you've got to own your part of
this and that means getting well and
getting healthy means owning the
transition out of this mess
there is no possible way this happens
cleanly
or or with that it can happen cleanly it
doesn't happen without chaos without
accusations without I'm not leaving
without somebody getting arrested
without there is no go ye gentle into
that good night that will not happen
here
just know that just know that but I'm
gonna treat her with dignity and respect
I've asked her to leave she won't leave
I'm going to call the sheriff in Texas
and I'm going to ask for assistance
removing somebody a former roommate from
my home because they will not leave
and um they should come help you out
and if they don't then it's time to get
a lawyer
and a lawyer will you will hire them to
work on your behalf but I but it's it's
time it's time it's time and then you my
brother are gonna have to do the hard
hard work
of making Community there in San Antonio
because you can't live in isolation you
can't live by yourself and you can't
continue to call people who are not well
to come in and try to try to
be that Band-Aid for you while you're
hurting man sorry you're going through
this my brother I wish you all the best
in the future
um
be very clear
ask for help receive help
and then for God's sake man create an
accountability plan so you don't find
yourself in these exact same situations
again in the future thanks for calling
my brother